why we don't want to just look at the
appeal to Nature that well our ancestors
ate that way what's the disconnect there
it just comes back to realizing what the
goal of our ancestors was and what
evolution is it's to get you to an age
to procreate Evolution does not care if
you have a heart attack in 60 if your
goal is to increase the number of years
that you live in good health you're
trying to shrink the number of years
where you're affected by disease then
you have to look to the science that is
studying people over time and looking at
biomarkers that predict longevity right
because we have different goals to our
ancestors yes we're not just here to
survive that was my friend Simon Hill
nutritionist and host of the proof
podcast who sat down with me to break
down today's most popular diets and
Trends it can be confusing to navigate
what dietary patterns are optimal for
our longevity and health with a master's
degree in nutrition Simon has a healthy
obsession with nutritional science and
helps clear the mud on this topic the
data on five is really clear there's a
dose-dependent relationship the more
fiber you have the lower risk of
colorectal cancer type 2 diabetes
various forms of cancer cardiovascular
disease and people are living longer if
you're interested in good health later
in life we have to look Beyond
speculation of what our ancestors may or
may not have eaten it's the other thing
to consider here when we're thinking
about like eating like our ancestors are
we truly eating like them or are we kind
of eating the foods that we want to eat
today and making ourselves feel good by
telling ourselves that that's the same
foods that they ate a long time ago he
explains the hierarchy of evidence to
establish which science holds more
weight than others why what's natural
isn't necessarily the best for our
long-term Health the truth about
saturated fat and the demonization of
pufas in our diet and we cover popular
diets from paleo to Western a price
nourishing tradition style diets keto
Carnivore Plant Paradox and break down
popular claims about butter bone broth
anti-nutrients seed oils and more while
science is not perfect we do have clear
biomarkers for longevity and preventing
our number one killers and this episode
goes into how these Trends stack up
against those markers they have charts
showing the increase in proof of
consumption shows an increase in these
types of diseases how do you respond to
that Simon published a best-selling book
which I highly recommend the proof is in
the plants with so many experts letting
their biases get in the way to form
nutritional recommendations Simon is the
nutritional resource we need right now
this year's clear of Dogma something
that very few people do and is simply
interested in the best evidence of the
truth they're not appreciating that they
can feel good today and still be
increasing their risk of disease in
decades to come because these things
bubble away under the surface
can you share your dietary thesis
philosophy with everyone so they kind of
know where we're coming from okay
starting with the big question
so I guess I probably
have a philosophy or a dietary approach
that is a little bit different to
what may be more common in certain diet
sort of groups or tribes where people
often sort of promote one diet as being
the absolute optimal for human health
there's a little bit more kind of nuance
in the position that that I take which
is less absolute in nature means it's
harder to sell it's a little bit less of
a sexy position to kind of take and I
understand that but
it's more in line with what the sign
shows and that's my aim with everything
that I do is to kind of
I hold myself to a very you know High
degree of accountability when it comes
to rigorously looking at the evidence
and presenting it as objectively as
possible irrespective of My Chosen diet
and when you look at the evidence there
is not a single diet and this is why
there's so much argument online there is
no evidence that you can point to that
would say this is definitively the
single absolute best way for every human
to eat for good health today and for
good long-term Health but what is clear
and that that often when people hear
that they think well we just does that
mean we have no idea no we have a very
good idea but it's more of a theme or
set of characteristics
and that that theme you know that time
and time again has been shown to reduce
risk of a lot of the chronic disease
burden that is really robbing people of
quality of life today cardiovascular
disease type 2 diabetes fatty liver
disease various types of cancers
Alzheimer's dementia
Etc
uh that theme that reduces the risk of
all of those conditions is a diet that's
low in saturated fat it has a bias for
unsaturated fats particularly
polyunsaturated fats I think that's
something we're probably going to talk
about definitely it's rich in fiber
and it's low in Ultra processed foods
right and those are probably like the
big kind of three things as well as
being low or hopefully excluding trans
fats which I think everyone agrees on
today
now so that's very broad what can that
look like it can be a very healthy uh
well thought out Mediterranean diet it
could be a pescetarian diet it could be
a vegetarian diet it could be a very
well planned Whole Food plant-based diet
these are all different variations of
that theme
and
I think that
rather than that being even though it's
less absolute rather than that being a
negative thing is actually quite
positive because it it gives People
Choice based on
what is going to be sustainable for them
because the most important thing is when
we're considering someone particularly
someone's long-term health is
what is a dietary pattern a way of
eating that they can stick to over time
and having more options means that more
people are likely to be successful and
we're failing massively when you look at
what the average diet looks like so we
need we need options and then when we
start to consider other aspects of our
life and our values the health of the
planet which is inextricably tied to our
own health and we think about Animal
Welfare that's where and in my book and
this comes back to original question
about my thesis that's where I think the
case becomes much stronger to adopt a
diet that's as plant exclusive as
possible for you and so you know in in a
nutshell that's kind of what my My
overall thesis is amazing and why why
have you become so passionate about this
why do you read so much science
when I was a little boy I would come
home and there'd be scientific papers
littered all around the home no way my
my dad's now being a professor for I
think 35 years going on still still to
this day and uh has been tremendously
successful professor of physiology and
Publishing in cell and metabolism and
all the major journals
so from a very early age I was
surrounded by
studies and I knew my dad was uh you
know had done his PhD and was spending a
lot of time in the in the lab I'd go in
and spend time with him my dad would be
wearing a white lab coat and had like
microscopes and I'd jump up and use
microscopes
and so I developed an appreciation for
what science is as a tool and it really
is just a tool to help us better
understand the world and through that we
can make better decisions it's not
perfect and science is about
reducing uncertainty
and I think that can kind of make some
people feel uncomfortable because
they're looking for the definitive
certain answer but really over time what
we're trying to do with the evidence
base is progressively move closer to a
truth right
with you know respect or whatever you
know topic that we're interested in so I
was kind of surrounded in that
environment growing up and always
thought this is pretty cool this is
something that I'd like to explore and
then I
you know finished high school and did an
undergraduate science degree and then
later on did a master's in nutrition
science and really what fascinates me is
when I look at kind of Wellness culture
and nutrition online there was a lot of
fighting there's a lot of absolute
positions and there's a lot of people
that are very very confident in those
positions
and it's actually you know if you if
you're going to be really confident in a
position whether it's you know something
about anti-nutrients or it's about
source of protein or it's about fiber
there's there's so much time that needs
to be invested into each of those topics
literally just to understand
anti-nutrients you know we could be
talking about months of research getting
getting across and you know like I'm I'm
quite
I think it's healthy but I'm quite
obsessed with like looking through that
literature and and so you know I kind of
feel like a lot of people are forming
very strong positions without having
done that work and and you know
inherently or just accepting a position
because it kind of Suits a a bias that
someone has or it sounds good like oh
this makes sense right Crosby right and
we do that when it fits with a bias so
if we've adopted a particular diet or
we've had a a sort of an equal one n
equals one
um personal experience with something we
can then go looking for evidence to
support that but that's really the the
reverse direction of what we should be
doing we should be starting with the
evidence base sorting it out filtering
through what's okay what's mechanistic
what's the strongest evidence and what
are the converging lines what's it all
pointing to that's how we actually look
at things through a more evidence-based
lens our anecdotal experience is
important I wouldn't say it's invalid
but
there's a lot of blind spots there so
over the years I've become incredibly
passionate about trying to educate
people about
the actual evidence base looking at
nutrition and helping people understand
how I come to my conclusions and also if
there's a claim that's out there you
know what's what's wrong with or why
would we not accept that claim and and
often you can you can look at sort of
logical inconsistencies you know
someone's taking a certain position on
something here and then
for another food or nutrient they're
taking they they're taking a very
different approach to how they're
looking at the evidence so you know I
find it I just find it the whole process
of looking at the evidence base and
trying to communicate it and help people
understand the principles you know
really interesting and and rewarding
yeah it's a really interesting topic to
navigate like is it only science that
dictates what's the truth or do you use
other facets you know because I think a
lot of these
um diets or trends that we're going to
be talking about today a lot of people
take the approach of either it makes
sense just in their head or biology or
Nature's appeal and and then like you
said looking for evidence that supports
that bias but do you at all use any of
that or is it just science to form your
opinions well I mean anthropology is is
a form of Science and biology and
mechanisms are a form of science so they
certainly come into it but you're right
I think there's a lot of kind of the the
naturalistic fail policy out there that
a lot of people subscribe to and and I
think that's a bit of a trap you know I
think that if we were to just live quote
unquote naturally you know I'm of the
view that that would not lead to the
most optimal lifespan and health span
and so I think it could be actually a
very miserable life if all you did was
try and live as naturally as possible so
you can think about the extent to which
you would need to do yeah to do that
um so
yeah I I sort of look at some of those
things as interesting like what maybe
what did our ancestors eat and you can
look at that and you can deduce some
things from it all right guys I have to
tell you about the Apothecary and Nema
Mundi herbals which carries organic wild
crafted and ethically grown Botanicals
every vibrant and medicinally potent
remedy is packaged in eco-friendly
packaging of recyclable glass or
biodegradable bags once you shop their
site you'll see what I mean there are so
many incredible goodies to get but if
you get just one thing you've got to get
their collagen beauty kit which is full
of plant magic to help support healthy
hair skin nails and Bones this kit
includes a dirty Rose chai collagen
which contains herbs known for their
collagen protecting and boosting effects
it also comes with their super fruit
collagen their signature formula
composed of collagen boosting plans
enhanced with the beautifying powers of
superfruits you also get an original
collagen booster powder a plant-based
blend that's the ultimate Beauty boost
with adaptogens ancient herbs and
flowers to support radiant hair glowing
skin and healthy nails and lastly it
comes with a collagen face oil and rose
quartz guasa the perfect addition which
feels Divine on my skin it would be an
amazing gift to give a loved one but if
not for someone special in your life at
least get it for yourself and anima
Moody herbals uses Fair Trade Practices
Beyond organic farming education and
small farmers to create remedies that
benefit people from all walks of life so
use my code Ellen 20 for 20 off just
click the link in my show notes to get
this deal
there are a number of pitfalls with
those arguments as well you know our our
ancestors for example we're eating to
survive that's what evolution is worried
about getting you to an age to procreate
maybe a little bit beyond that
um and and so they were choosing Foods
in the environment the the foods that
were available to them to help them
survive that doesn't speak to the types
of things that I'm necessarily
interested in or a lot of my community
and listeners are interested in which is
how can they get to 60 70 and 80 and not
develop a certain type of cancer or not
develop heart disease or not have a
stroke how can they actually just enjoy
their life
for longer and so you know anthropology
and what our ancestors they can only
kind of tell us so much and and you know
even even then I don't think there is
one ancestral diet I think the evidence
is pretty clear that it varied a lot
over time so how far back are we going
to go what geographical location there's
there's a lot of kind of variables and
speculation there yeah right now the
term ancestral is extremely trendy and
yet if you do call it trendy people can
kind of get upset like no it's not it's
ancestral that's what it is but really
like you said how far back do you want
to go there's so many different types of
ancestral diets so are you deciding
which type of ancestral diet is the best
for you paleo nourishing Traditions type
style we have keto carnivore all that
stuff a lot of it is kind of lumped like
you said like you've said before under
an umbrella term of ancestral yeah I
think firstly we probably should
acknowledge that there are a number of
good things about those diets and I you
know the big obvious one is that they're
focused on Whole Foods and not Ultra
processed you know highly palatable
energy dance
refined sugar and fat dense foods and it
is those Ultra processed foods that make
up you know 60 of the average person's
calories they're driving you know an
enormous amount of the overweight
obesity sort of epidemic that we see
which is then linked to a lot of the
poor metabolic Health that we see
whether it's type 2 diabetes or
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
those types of metabolic conditions are
pretty much entirely driven by energy
toxicity consuming too many calories and
so as soon as you take these Ultra
processed foods off the table we all
know as you're when you're focused on
Whole Foods you tend to eat much less
calories and that's been shown you know
in clinical studies really high level
studies Kevin Hall at the NIH did a
study looking at a
unprocessed whole food diet versus an
ultra processed food diet and he
actually matched in the foods
protein and fat and sugars and even
fiber and he had these people basically
locked up in a metabolic Ward and it was
an ad libidum study which means you can
eat as much as you want eat until you're
satisfied and the great thing about that
is you can get a feel for satiety you
know how full were people were people
filling up on one of those diets earlier
and eating less calories and it was also
crossover study so if you were in the
study you got to do the unprocessed diet
for a couple weeks and then you'd switch
over and people did it in different
orders so it's a very like considered a
very high quality type of study and on
average when people were eating the
ultra processed diet even though they
matched for those different factors
which doesn't happen in the real world
they were eating 500 calories more per
day it makes complete sense so you know
right off the bat here we can say like
if someone's adopting a diet that is
quote unquote ancestral whichever
variation it might be there are some
subtle differences differences between
the these different dietary patterns and
some I think are better than others but
but straight away that's going to to
lead to many people losing weight which
leads to many Health improvements and
improvements in biomarkers that predict
disease whether that's their fasting
glucose or their triglycerides you know
things of blood pressure things of that
nature so
I think that's a big tick for these
diets and something that would kind of
Overlook is like the agreement between
people coming at at nutrition from
different angles you know they're 60 of
of someone's calories
where I think these diets get a few
things wrong is back to that theme that
I mentioned at the start I said it has
it de-emphasizes saturated fat it has
more of an emphasis on polyunsaturated
fats
and there's a there's a couple of really
important reasons for that one is in the
literature it's very clear that when you
swap calories from saturated fat for
polyunsaturated fat we see an
improvement in a number of important
biomarkers we see an improvement in LDL
cholesterol more specifically APO B if
anyone's kind of familiar with that
essentially the same same sort of thing
or telling us a similar information
and we also see an improvement in
insulin sensitivity so your body's
ability to shuttle glucose into cells
and use it
and in the context of someone who is
eating excess calories and a lot of
people are eating excess calories you
can eat an ancestral diet and still be
eating excess calories in the context of
eating you know above what your daily
energy requirements are if you're
gaining weight on an ancestral diet with
a lot of saturated fat
you can bet and it'll vary depending on
your genetics but you can bet it's not
just subcutaneous fat under your skin on
your face or your hips or wherever it's
going to be visceral fat we know that
saturated fat really drives up the fat
in the liver and also in the pancreas
there's clinical trial after clinical
trial showing that whereas when you swap
those calories from saturated fat for
polyunsaturated fats you see a reduction
in this very harmful ectopic fat is what
it's called scientifically in the liver
and in the pancreas so you know one of
the things that I I kind of almost laugh
at is
you know within these crowds they often
promote these diets as best for
metabolic health
and I would argue very strongly that
that's not true the liver is the the
master regulator of essentially of your
metabolic health and metabolism and if
you're increasing the fat levels in the
liver and in the pancreas you are
increasing insulin resistance you're
reducing your body's ability to utilize
glucose and so if you think about
metabolism and metabolic Health broadly
my definition would be that you're
really good at being able to utilize
fats and carbohydrates that's true
metabolic flexibility but if you're
eating in a way that is making you
really poor at utilizing carbohydrates I
would argue that you're actually you're
actually
shifting your metabolic Health in an
unfavorable Direction so that would be
kind of like one of the the major
disagreements
um between myself and someone who's
putting forward a more sort of ancestral
diet would that be specific like Keto
keto carnivore where they're not eating
fruits and potatoes and things like that
or are you also speaking that to someone
who eats quote unquote ancestrally but
they're all they're eating a wide
variety of fruits and so if it is Nuance
here for us to explore and and maybe we
can kind of Step through that but this
is also an area that trips people up so
when I'm using the word saturated fat
right now and I've been doing that kind
of purposefully to keep it high level
but if we want to step to that next
level deeper
saturated fats and umbrella tone so not
all saturated fats are the same when
we're when we're reviewing the evidence
to look at is something healthy or
harmful we have to be really specific so
what type of saturated fats are we
talking about how much
if someone was replacing those saturated
fats what are they replacing it with
and for whom what are their genetics
okay all of these make a a really big
difference
um does it vary based on those different
diets it depends on where someone's
getting their saturated fats from
uh we know like saturated fats that are
found in red meat and also in butter
tend to drive LDL cholesterol and APO B
up quite a lot
much more than the saturated fats in
Dairy so you can go and look at a study
and there's one Chen at Al has done a
meta-analysis which is often cited which
shows that that the saturated fats in
Dairy compared to red meat
sorry when I say Dairy I'm not talking
about butter I'm talking about the other
forms of dairy those saturated fats in
yogurt and in cheese do not increase LDL
cholesterol APO b as much as red meat
does and you could point to that study
and say see look dairy's you know
positive for cholesterol well relative
to red meat it is but in that same study
they also looked at well how do those
saturated fats in Dairy compare to
polyunsaturated fats in plant foods and
you see it you see a step again a
beneficial step by swapping calories
from
Dairy and milk and cheese for these
plant fats so compared to what is like
really important when we're trying to
dig into this research and and make
sense of it my
kind of take-home message here for the
listener because how do you make sense
of all of that they just want to know
okay but I just want to know like is is
a saturated fat in my diet is it is it a
problem yeah don't measure your APO B
level so what is able B I think a lot of
people don't know what that is can you
explain it we've spoken about the the
two energy sources so far glucose and
fats and you know most people will
probably realize that that Sugar just
kind of freely flows in the in
circulation it's water soluble and our
Plasma in our blood is mostly water so
we don't have to have something that
kind of chaperones or carries glucose it
can just dissolve in move through
circulation and go to cells we cannot do
the same with fats right fats are water
insoluble so through Evolution our body
had to come up with an answer how are we
going to get these fats to our cells
and what it does is a protein
which is water soluble you can almost
imagine like a beach ball imagine that
the outside of that is the protein which
is water-soluble and we're going to
stuff the fat in the middle of that and
now that can go into circulation and it
can dissolve and then we can carry that
through the blood
and hopefully get it to the tissues that
that need it
there are
another actually analogy here that can
be helpful for people to kind of think
about is a cargo ship they're not like a
cargo ship that's carrying different
um containers you know across the sea
right
the cargo ship you can think about as
the protein and on top of that those
containers are are cholesterol and
triglycerides fats
there's essentially two different
families of these cargo ships one of
them is called APO B and the other one's
called APO A1
don't we don't need to think about APO
A1 right now these APO B
containing lipoproteins which is what
they're called all of them have the
capacity as they're floating through
circulation to enter the artery wall get
retained cause inflammation and build up
this fatty Park
ninety percent of APO B
containing lipoproteins are LDL
low density lipoproteins
the other 10 are called IDL and VL deals
when you measure your APO B directly you
get the summation of LDL plus IDL plus
vldl okay okay so you get and this is
particularly important for about 20 of
the population where LDL cholesterol
doesn't correlate with a per B
you get a much better idea of your risk
of cardiovascular disease by going and
requesting APO b or if that's not
available to someone there on our on
standard blood test usually you can get
non-hdl which is again better than LDL
cholesterol
point being is
when you measure your a per b or non-hdl
there's reference ranges
so go and get your test done okay if
you're high on those
then you might want to go back to your
diet
and understanding that the biggest lever
that you can pull to reduce those is to
swap calories from saturated fats for
polyunsaturated fats which in food form
means less Meats less butter in
particular endless dairy fat if you're
having a lot of it and then more
fatty fish if you eat seafood or nuts
seeds avocado tofu these kind of foods
that's what that would look like so why
is it so important to reduce it so this
comes back to the liver and I said it's
like the master regulator of of
metabolic Health one of the important
functions of the liver is it has these
receptors on it these LDL receptors and
these receptors take up the APO B
particles right so that you can imagine
that the issue with these April B
containing lipoproteins in circulation
is when they when they become too
elevated you get more of them crashing
into the artery wall and getting
retained it's part of normal physiology
to have these you know I mentioned it's
it's taking fats out to cells so it's
not a case of trying to get it to to
zero
um but different bats have different
effect on the LDL receptor saturated
fats decrease the sensitivity of that
receptor so if you imagine that receptor
is like a bit like a gate okay and it's
allowing these apobs back into the liver
out of circulation so it helps lower the
level of APO B in circulation that's one
of the the liver's jobs
when you eat a lot of saturated fat you
start to close that gate they can't get
back into the liver so what happens
they're building up imagine you're back
to the analogy of this the cargo ship
imagine you're looking at a port
and the the guys on the cranes have gone
on strike they're not clearing the
containers you have all of these cargo
ships building up in that Port right and
now these cargo ships have uh you know
they're hanging around for longer they
can throw their anchor down and build up
and get stuck
um so saturated fats are reducing the
receptor the LDL receptor sensitivity
polyunsaturated fats do the exact
opposite so polyunsaturated fats open
the gate up they help deliver clear
these APO B containing lipoproteins
so that's the biggest lever that someone
can pull and that's very clear there's
metabolic Ward clinical studies where
they lock people up and feed them
saturated fats and polyunsaturated fats
and measure all of this stuff in fact
there's a meta-analysis of 395
experiments clock and I can put that
into the show notes that tested this
exactly
um
so again you know you can't really
change or intentionally change something
if you don't measure it and
so back to your question about like how
does someone know and is there a
difference between these different types
of diets who really comes back to the
type of saturated fats they're eating
what foods are they in and also their
genetics so that ability for saturated
fat to shut the gait and polyunsaturated
fats to open it is also modulated by our
genes so for example I might be able to
get away with a little bit more
saturated fat than you and that could be
a genetic thing right so so it's not
going to be such a drastic difference
it's not going to be drastic uh huge
differences but it is important to
acknowledge that you know when we look
at studies you get the typical response
the average response none of us are
exactly representative of average so you
have to take the information and then
you know the broad theme and then
individualize it and personalize it
based on your lab results based on how
you're feeling and this is one of those
examples where you look at an important
risk factor and then you can you know
you can make a decision Vision if you
want to try and change certain aspects
of your diet so the lab results part is
really interesting to me because I want
to back up and I think a lot of people
might be thinking okay but how do I know
that what you're saying is true because
this other guy over here tells me that
saturated fat is actually really good
for me and it doesn't cause our biggest
Killers how do I know what is true and
poofas are like the worst thing ever
you know how you back up and help people
to see that what you're saying is
because of the the evidence the body of
evidence we have very strong data on
saturated fats and hard Health outcomes
which means looking at clinical trials
comparing groups that are either
randomized so these are randomized
controlled trials compare people that
are randomized to saturated fat
intervention or polyunsaturated fat
intervention and there's now so many of
those clinical trials that you can do a
meta-analysis so Cochrane review which
is considered one of the highest quality
meta-analysis meta-analyzes that can
exist or group that does them they did a
2020 meta-analysis of this and looked at
exactly that all those trials put
together what do we see you see a 21
reduction in coronary heart disease when
you swap calories from saturated fat for
polyunsaturated fat it's very hard to
argue with right those are hard Health
outcome studies right we're looking at
people over time who are either eating
saturated fat or polyunsaturated fats
and how many of them are having a heart
attack now
um we can take that a step further
because it's not it's not just that we
understand that saturated fat is uh
people that eat more saturated fat have
more heart disease we actually
understand
the primary mechanism by which that
occurs and it comes back to what I just
mentioned before that saturated fat is
reducing your liver's ability to clear
these APO B containing lipoproteins that
are mostly ldls
um and they build up and we have a huge
body of evidence showing that LDL
cholesterol is causal right it directly
causes atherosclerosis so that buildup
of that fatty plaque is caused by an
elevation in LDL cholesterol more
specifically these April B containing
lipoproteins so you might say well
what's that evidence okay well we have
observational studies which are the
weakest form of evidence I'm going to to
point to
tens and tens we have millions of person
you uh follower follow-up looking at
people over time
how much saturated fat are they eating
what's their risk of heart disease and
we see very clearly across the world
cohorts all across the world different
cultures people who eat more saturated
fat have a higher risk of have elevated
LDL cholesterol and have a higher risk
of coronary heart disease
and it's linear the more the LDL
cholesterol goes up the higher their
risk of heart disease so that's like
evidence one
evidence too we have these mendelian
studies which is a fancy word
essentially for genetic studies so
you can be born with certain gene
mutations that either lower your LDL
cholesterol or increase it and these are
these are incredible studies because if
you think about it it's kind of like
Nature's randomized controlled trial you
know you have mummy Daddy really have no
say just pop out and you've you've been
randomized to having super low LDL
cholesterol or super high
what do we see well and and this is
really interesting because these are
people that are exposed to that level of
cholesterol over a lifetime and we know
that that's super important lifetime
exposure same as cigarettes yeah it's
now being called cholesterol use
so there are you know there's so much
evidence showing that people who are
born with a genetic mutation that
results in super elevated LDL
cholesterol these people can have a
cardiac event when they're teenagers
many of them die in their 20s if they're
if they're untreated yeah okay then we
see the exact opposite that people who
have super low LDL cholesterol
incredibly low risk of heart disease if
they're if they're like won the genetic
Lottery and their LDL cholesterol is
just crazy low down at physiologic
levels like 30 milligrams per deciliter
these people are not getting heart
disease okay so that's that's number two
and then
um you know number three is randomized
controlled trials so you take people
later in life once they have
cardiovascular disease usually you give
them a drug that lowers their LDL
cholesterol and you look at hard end
points what happens do they have less
heart attacks are they are they less
likely to die and you see the same thing
again
now you in those studies people often
point to the fact that the risk
reduction is is not huge and I like to
remind people that you can only do so
much when you're 65 and you start to
intervene after decades and decades and
Decades of pounding saturated fat and
having all this damage and plaque
accumulation in the artery you can't
expect to have the same risk reduction
that you would have if you won the
genetic Lottery and had low cholesterol
from birth right so that's why we see
different risk reductions between the
genetic studies and the clinical trials
but we so we have that observational
data we have genetic studies and we have
randomized controlled trials all telling
us the same thing that when you get LDL
cholesterol down people have less events
heart attacks and and strokes so I think
that's pretty compelling evidence it's
not certainly not something that you
know I would want to ignore I've got
cardiovascular disease in my family I
watch my dad have a heart attack at 41.
um so I take this stuff pretty seriously
you know I kind of I want to get to 50
60 70 and and you know hopefully be in
good health and uh you know not rushed
off to hospital having some sort of
cardiac event totally I mean that's
really compelling evidence So for
anybody who maybe is skeptical of
research and Science and wants to look
back more at the appeal to Nature type
of look how do you respond to that when
they because you you sort of touch on it
but can you go into a little bit further
about why we don't want to just look at
the appeal to Nature that well our
ancestors ate that way what is what's
the disconnect there well I think we
just have to it just comes back to
realizing like what the goal of of our
ancestors was and what evolution is it's
to get you to an age to procreate
Evolution does not care if you have a
heart attack at 60. Evolution does not
care if you have a heart attack at 70.
it doesn't care if you get cancer at 60
or 70. right so if you're interested in
good health later in life we have to
look Beyond speculation of what our
ancestors may or may not have eaten and
back to what I said earlier I don't even
think we can put our finger on like this
is the ancestral diet you can get some
general themes but there's no way of of
doing that so you know I think you can
you can look at that and be interested
in it but if your goal is to increase
the number of years that you live in
good health which is essentially
increasing your health span you're
trying to shrink the number of years
where you're affected by disease
then you have to look to the science
that is stunning people over time and
looking at biomarkers that predict
longevity right because we have
different goals to our ancestors yes
we're not just here to survive we have
so many food
options available to us that our
ancestors didn't and so we're in this
privileged position of saying okay we
don't have to just go out and eat
calories to survive and eat whatever we
can get our hands on we can actually
look at the science that we have and
make a more calculated decision and
increase our chance of getting to 60 65
without developing cancer without having
a heart attack without having a stroke
and so hopefully to our 80s and 90s yeah
exactly and the other thing to consider
here is the types of foods that our
ancestors were eating and whether they
are the same as the types of foods that
people who are adopting different
variations of these ancestral diets are
eating today specifically meat so
there's a really interesting paper by
Lauren cordain who is kind of like the
father or one of the fathers of the
paleo diet and he wanted to look at what
are the the typical cholesterol levels
in hunter-gatherer tribes anyone can go
out and look at this and there's a
beautiful graph in there and
with the data that's available to us
looking at different hunter-gatherer
tribes we know that their cholesterol
levels are not high
now you might think well how can that be
if they're eating a lot of animal foods
that are rich in saturated fats What's
Happening Here
well
there's good kind of archaeological
evidence that suggests the types of
meats that our ancestors are eating were
probably a lot leaner than the types of
meats today so Lena then then beef and
lamb you know our ancestors would have
been eating woolly mammoth and Antelope
and and you know venison type of type of
meat so
um you know that's that's the other
thing to kind of consider here when
we're thinking about like eating like
our ancestors are we truly eating like
them or are we kind of just eating the
foods that we want to eat today and
making ourselves feel good by you know
telling ourselves that that's the same
foods that they ate a long time ago so
that's the kind of you know that's the
way that that I think about that
who might be asked
they may not be thinking that far down
the road and so it's easy to just go to
this oh yeah this makes sense this you
know nature this is how our ancestors
ate not realizing that there are certain
foods that definitely prevent our
biggest killer so when you take that
evidence into consideration it kind of
goes against that personal bias that you
would have but can you go into pufas
then because this is kind of their big
pushback on that explanation about
saturated fat as well look at the charts
they have charts showing like the
increase in proof of consumption shows
an increase in these types of diseases
how do you respond to that firstly
that's some of the most weakest data
that you can present that's called
ecological so okay so why is it what I
find is interesting because it's
unadjusted so you can basically just go
out and look at two different Trends and
show an association right if if you go
out and say in the last uh 100 years
poofers have increased and obesity has
increased therefore proofers must be
causing obesity there's so many other
things that have also changed during
that period people are more sedentary
people are eating 60 of their calories
from Ultra processed foods now they may
contain poofers but that doesn't so that
doesn't mean that poofers are inherently
a problem doesn't mean that's the poop
yeah right there's so many different
things in there yeah and they're hyper
palatable they're low protein they're
low water they're low fiber all of these
different Myriad of characteristics that
can lead to over consumption I kind of
look at that ecological Association and
mind you what is left out there often is
that purpose have gone up since 1960
cardiovascular disease mortality has
halved since 1960. they're inverse so I
could sit here and create the same
argument and say we've increased poofers
dramatically since 1960 and less people
are dying of cardiovascular disease I
think it's a pretty weak argument I
wouldn't really make it but that's the
kind of same kind of logic so for anyone
too saying like what is a [__] is a
polyunsaturated did Fat so this this
essentially high level there's there's
four different types of fats saturated
fats trans fats monounsaturated fats
with that one double double bond
polyunsaturated fats with two or more
the foods that are richest in in
polyunsaturated fats are fatty fish your
walnuts chia seeds flax seeds these
types of foods and then monounsaturated
fats are rich in like avocados and olive
oil and saturated fats tend to be
richest in animal foods but not
exclusively so there are some plant
foods like coconut oil and palm oil
which are the two tropical oils that are
rich in in saturated fat the claims
around polyunsaturated fats that I've
seen are that people say they increase
inflammation and people say that they're
obesogenic they increase body weight and
that they increase risk of
cardiovascular disease now we've just
spoken to the clinical studies that
contradict the cardiovascular disease
point
I think the most compelling evidence
that we have that we can look at here
for just polyunsaturated fats in general
and if people need to be worried about
them do we need to fear them right I'm
not paid by big polyunsaturated fats
yeah I could quite easily have low
polyunsaturated fats and any
monounsaturated fats but the evidence
suggests if you're limiting
polyunsaturated fats in your diet you're
leaving Health on the table
which is so contradictory to this world
of eating and at what they advocate for
it's like pufas are the worst especially
specifically seed oils like but a lot of
that's also the net the naturalistic
fallacy it's how they're produced
they'll show videos of the production
and say look this can't be healthy and
you know I think that's interesting but
I think again you have to go and look at
the evidence that we have and we have
really solid evidence that shows
and it's not just observational evidence
where you do a dietary assessment and
then look at outcomes the neat thing
with polyunsaturated fats is that
they're essential our body doesn't make
them so when you measure them in
circulation or in tissues what does that
mean that means they must have come in
through your diet like as opposed to
saturated fats right so you can that our
body anyone who doesn't know that our
body makes yeah so our body can make
saturated fats
the
there are studies large population
studies where they not only do a dietary
assessment they actually measure they do
it at a either serum so looking at
circulation or adipose tissue looking at
the actual levels of linoleic acid which
is an omega-6 so it's the type of
polyunsaturated fat it is the the
polyunsaturated fat that is most rich in
seed oils right so in these studies with
tens and tens of thousands of people
they go and measure how much linoleic
acid omega-6 is in their fat tissue and
is in circulation
and then they look at okay based on
the variance in these levels is there a
difference in health outcomes do the
people that have more linoleic acid in
their in their fat stored in their body
do they have an increase in certain
diseases are they living longer are they
living shorter what do you see you see
people that have more linoleic acid
these polyunsaturated fats in their
tissues is in their body
okay they have lower risk of
cardiovascular disease they have lower
risk of dying from cardiovascular
disease and they have lower risk of
total mortality which means death from
all causes these people with more
linoleic acid and I'll link to this
study because if if if anyone is of the
view that polyunsaturated fats are
harmful you have to read this paper
there's there's multiple papers I'll
give you a couple of them
people that have more
linoleic acid in their tissue have lower
total mortality they're living longer so
I I look at that data and I find it very
hard to take the position that
polyunsaturated fats are harmful and
that we need to avoid them what about
the difference though between like a
whole Walnut versus Canola oil
right is it is are many of the studies
understand the difference there are they
looking at the difference there are some
studies that have attempted to look at
the difference between oils and Whole
Foods like olive oil and nuts and you
know generally my view I think the whole
food is probably better and I say that
mostly because you're getting slightly
better nutrition but also from a satiety
point of view oil is a very calorie
dense so if someone's goal is to lose
weight lowering the calorie density of
the diet is is a good thing but at the
same same by the same you know at the
same time I
I wouldn't generate fear over over oils
at all if someone's cooking with those
oils in their diet and it's a healthy
body weight and they're not gaining
weight then it's a way better option
than butter with butter right that's
super interesting which is now you know
ironically is being marketed as a
superfood again yeah butter butter is a
superfood now guys it's back and forth
back and forth you just never know what
it is but you feel like the science is
pretty clear it's not really back or
forth like if we go back to where I kind
of begun with saturated fat the reason
that you can you'll see different views
out there is people are not considering
the context what is the dose of
saturated fat what type of saturated fat
what's it being compared to and who are
the people in the study and if you don't
consider that context you can get easily
confused on this topic and so when it
comes to processed food Ultra processed
foods then oil is a component the those
processed oils like canola oil and
different seed oils they are a component
of their Ultra processed food so what is
it that makes Ultra processed foods
unhealthy is it just the fact that it's
their calorie dense and low in nutrients
or is it more than that it could it be
that it's oh it's the fact that it's
isolated foods like processed sugar and
oils and lack of fiber and low in
nutrients all of that to answer that is
still up for debate right people are
still looking at it but I mean if you if
you think about it just generally we
know that they're hyper palatable and
they lead to excessive calorie
consumption and we know that that energy
toxicity is really damaging I think that
it's a two-fold kind of problem here one
is that these foods are they're low
fiber they're low water they're usually
low protein they're calorie dense all of
these things leads to over consumption
right they're not great from a satiety
point of view filling you up on fewer
calories yeah but and lower less
nutrients the other thing is what's the
opportunity cost when you're eating
these Foods what are you not eating
other foods that have inherent benefits
that come with a lot of nutrition fruits
and vegetables and legumes these types
of foods are being pushed out of the
diet so I think you see the the net
effect on health is a summation of those
two things
yes I think that's a missing component
people are often thinking about like if
I eat if I'm eating this Ultra processed
food every single day for every snack
every day or every lunch then you're
missing the opportunity to eat whole
plant foods with lots of vegetables and
fresh fruits and nutrient dense calories
I think we can get into now specifics on
some of the claims of these Trends and I
think maybe we should first cut like
round out the topic of butter it's very
becoming very popular now that oh we're
getting back to the way that our great
grandparents lived on a farm and they
milk their own cow and then we make our
own butter and it's so healthy for us
why is it not so healthy for us other
than what you already explained the big
two raisins are hypo B so it's going to
increase APO B we're gonna remember
heart disease is the number one
cause of death globally it's the most
likely reason that any of the listeners
are going to die right so you should
take that pretty seriously if there's a
biomarker you're going to be most
interested in it's a per B
um I also mentioned that saturated fat
so butter is very rich in saturated fats
and particularly these saturated fats
that increase hepatic fat so increase
that fat that's building up in the liver
it's building up in the pancreas it
leads to insulin resistance so from a
metabolic Health it's going to be
damaging there compared to eating foods
that are rich in any unsaturated fats
whether that's monounsaturated fats or
polyunsaturated fats
um so you know I think that the the
reason that this is trendy is because
people see it as kind of natural
ancestral but they're not appreciating
that they can feel good today and still
be increasing their risk of disease in
decades to come because these things
bubble away under the surface that's
that I feel good in this way I'm you
know I'm eating these Whole Foods from
animal products as a basis of my diet
and I feel good so how could I possibly
be you know promoting the disease of of
the majority of what Americans are
eating because they see that the
majority of Americans are eating lots of
ultra processed foods so they think well
I'm doing it differently I'm eating
Whole Foods it's just like largely from
animal sources but they think that's
very different than what the state of
American is eating that are also dying
of so and it is better and and it makes
sense that they feel good relative to a
standard American diet eating that way
absolutely it's just not necessarily
necessarily representative of how
they're going to feel in 20 30 40 years
so it it comes back to what are you
valuing and what are your goals here
right if you're if you're just thinking
about the here and now and how you feel
today you're not so concerned about
you know 20 30 40 years down the track
then maybe maybe that doesn't matter
well I mean I do think people do care
about that but they're thinking that
it's not going to cause that because
there's they are so
um convinced that it's actually like the
pufas that are causing the science is
very clear that there is a theme that is
consistent with long-term good long-term
health and that is a diet that is low in
saturated fats it's rich in polyancy
trade fats it's low in Ultra processed
foods this is not debated in nutrition
in the academic science world it's only
debated online it's it is absolutely the
consensus position with regards to how
do we get people to feel really good
today and feel better long term and I
can empathize with someone who adopts
you know quote-unquote ancestral kind of
diet and feels better today I would just
urge them to consider some food swaps
and look some people feel better on a
low carbohydrate diet some people lose
more weight on a low carbohydrate diet
some people lose more weight on a high
carb diet we know that's very clear in
the trials multiple ways to do it why
that is the case not so sure yet it
hasn't been elucidated is it genetics
is it something to do with the food
reward systems and differences between
people
um unsure but but what I would urge
someone who's adopted that that style of
eating is to within that framework what
are the changes you can make that are
going to shift some of these very potent
risk factors in the right direction
right how are we going to get your
visceral fat down that fat out of your
liver and out of your pancreas how are
we going to get APO B down and can you
do that in a way where you still feel
happy and you enjoy your diet that's
kind of you know the position that I
would take with that do you think
listing out the different types of diets
that are trendy right now that maybe are
super high in saturated fat or very high
in saturated fat but they are have
different variations different kinds of
sets of guidelines do you think they are
very different from each other or pretty
similar from each other some of them are
kind of more of a step in the right
direction I think than others like you I
mean if you go fully to the far far left
you're at a carnivore all mate diet with
no fiber and you know the the data on
five is really clear there's a dose
dependent relationship the more fiber
you have the lower risk of colorectal
cancer type 2 diabetes various forms of
cancer cardiovascular disease and people
are living longer and that actually
doesn't seem to tap out at 30 35 grams a
day which is what the recommendations
are average person's only getting about
15. it seems to go beyond that right and
and there's just not enough people in
these studies consuming 50 grams plus to
get a sort of fully appreciate that but
certainly so if you if we were kind of
looking at different ancestral diets I
think the ones that lean in more to
different types of fruits and some
vegetables and so they they're consuming
more fiber I think those are a healthier
variation of those types of diets and
and I bet if it was to be studied and
you compared all these different types
those
people that are eating in that way with
more of a high fiber approach they would
have healthier their risk factors would
look better than the people who are just
going completely carnivore very high
saturated fat and and no or very low
fiber what about the difference between
a dietary pattern that excludes Dairy
and does a lot of different kinds of
meat like maybe chicken and turkey
and fruits and vegetables versus a diet
that is rich in red meat and butter and
cheese and whole milk and also fruits
and vegetables how do you compare those
two
animal Foods in your diet and you wanted
to do it in the most helpful manner it's
the Mediterranean diet it's a diet that
has more of an emphasis on fatty fish it
has a low emphasis on red and white meat
I don't think that white meat is
particularly is is there's not much
signal to suggest it's much better than
red meat both of them seem to be just as
kind of problematic as one another that
doesn't mean that you can't have any red
or white meat in your diet this is
another area where people get very
confused they're the dose of a lot of
these things is the poison and so when
you even if you look at the red meat
literature
and you look at unprocessed red meat
I think this is super interesting and
this is something that many in the vegan
Community are not appreciating or
communicating and I think that's a bias
yeah right but I as I said at the start
I think you should just just put the
information out as it is and if you want
to argue about the planet planet or
Animal Welfare that's that's separate so
when you look at the red meat
um literature that we have there's
really conflicting results so some
studies suggest that red meat is not
increasing risk of cardiovascular
disease or colorectal cancer they're
like the big two that that come up with
red unprocessed red meat whereas other
studies suggest it is so why the
difference you know had science confused
here again dig into the study studies
look at the context so what you see is
very consistently in North America
when you compare high and low
unprocessed red meat intake
you see an increase in risk of
cardiovascular disease colorectal cancer
when you look at Asian covorts and you
compare high and low
tend not to say that
here's the really important thing when
you're comparing high and low those are
just relative things it really depends
what is high and what is like as well
and in Asia they're not consuming much
unprocessed red meat so when you're
comparing high and low they're both
actually low and they're very close
together so of course you don't see a
difference interesting when you look at
the American cohorts and now you get
this beautiful contrast because you get
some people that have 150 grams of red
meat a day unprocessed some people have
very little now you can see signal you
see increased risk of colorectal cancer
increased risk of cardiovascular disease
so instead of like looking at you know
just part of that evidence and and
choosing the one that suits you let's
look at all of it and realize that
probably what we're seeing here is that
the dose matters a lot and so when
you're getting up over 100 grams of
unprocessed red meat a day it seems
pretty consistent that you're increasing
your risk of cardiovascular disease and
colorectal cancer so
if I was to eat a diet that contained
animal foods and I certainly think you
can adopt a healthy diet that does
contain animal Foods it would be a very
plant-rich Mediterranean diet that's
featuring more
fatty fish and legumes and some whole
grains fruits and vegetables nuts and
seeds and olive oil and then it
de-emphasizes the kind of inclusion of
both white and red meat interesting and
then what about the dairy component
because these two types of diet options
I was explaining I think would be more
like a Paleo that's excluding Dairy
versus like a western a western a price
nurturing Traditions type diet
that eats a lot of dairy the the
evidence on Dairy is pretty interesting
as well
so I think you know firstly it depends
on what you're comparing it to I think
Dairy can be part of a healthy dietary
pattern
but uh it probably comes down to what
type of dairy are we talking about and
um you know
how much is someone consuming yeah so
can we get some concrete like what does
how much those different rates of too
much not as much
probably one or two serves a day of
yogurt and cheese yogurt and cheese like
the fermented dairy seem to be the ones
that are either neutral or perhaps even
in some circumstances beneficial
um you know they're providing calcium
and protein and so if you were to
replace them I think you can have a
dairy-free diet and be just as healthy
but their replacement's really important
you're replacing with foods that are
rich in calcium rich in in protein and
have fermented foods in your diet so
um that's why though what you're
replacing it is so important when you
said it can be beneficial it's like okay
if you're taking out red meat and butter
and swapping it for yogurt that is
beneficial correct but if you take out
these dairy foods and instead eat Ultra
processed foods that's probably a move
in the wrong direction right yeah so it
depends what you replace it with if
you're if you replace it with
um you know a soy yogurt for example or
soy milk you're moving in the in a step
in the right direction
um so that's important and then just
realizing that the saturated fats in
Dairy do have a different effect on our
body than the saturated fats in red meat
and the reason why butter is so
problematic is that butter is a heavily
refined food massively refined and so to
to make butter you actually have to
essentially you change the structure of
the food Matrix and in in cheese in
yogurt in less processed forms of dairy
the saturated fats are suspended in
what's called a milk fat globule and
that that milk fat globule reduces the
effect that saturated fats have on our
APO B cholesterol and cholesterol in
butter you break that milk fat globule
down so now these saturated fats are all
of a sudden much more potent okay so
let's talk a little about some other
specific claims like bone broth that's a
really big one right now the bone broth
is super nourishing very good for you it
enhances your health in all different
kinds of ways what does the evidence say
about that
I think they they think that bone broth
contains you know certain minerals and
amino acids and collagen
and so therefore they assume that this
is good for gut health and skin and hair
and stuff like that but I think strong
clients do require strong evidence
and is literally a debt there's like no
evidence looking at how bone broth
affects human health
there's one safety study which I think
is important because these like bone
broth and gelatin these can be highly
concentrated in heavy metals like lead
cadmium so there was one study that
looked into that because people were
concerned and that study seemed to
suggest that at least in that sample
that the levels were actually probably
safe for humans which is good but it
could be highly variable depending on
where you're sourcing this from
um but in terms of like the benefits of
it there's just no clinical data so it's
all anecdotal without having a control
in place you have no idea like you need
to have a control in place to understand
like how much of the benefit is Placebo
driven by Placebo how much of it is
driven by the actual constituents in
this food and how it interacts with your
physiology the studies that do exist are
looking at kind of mice and it's very
hard to extrapolate from those papers
yeah totally and what about real vitamin
A that's something that you hear a lot
that you need you shouldn't be eating
you know you shouldn't be getting your
vitamin A from Plants because of the
conversion and need real vitamin A
retinol
so be our body will convert
beta-carotene to vitamin A and unless
you have a specific gene mutation that
is really downshifting that conversion
your body will convert enough and we
know that and we I can I can link to a
uh one study there's many but a study
out of Switzerland that was looking at
omnivores vegetarians and vegans the
vegans were eating a very high quality
diet we know that because they were
consuming about 35 to 40 grams of fiber
a day really important when you're
looking at these studies to kind of work
out is this like a junk food vegan diet
or is it a healthy one yeah they seem to
be representative of a healthy diet and
these were kind of middle-aged adults
and they assessed their actual vitamin A
level serum vitamin A Levels and they
were completely fine in the in the vegan
group across the board no issues at all
so uh is there genetic anomalies and is
there is there going to be individuals
out there who maybe are not as good at
converting beta-carotene yeah for sure
so you know back to what I said earlier
we know the general characteristics of
healthy diets we know what works for the
typical person for most people but there
is some level of individualization that
you need to explore here right which is
my Approach is understand the theme and
then explore the individualization
within that theme and you know kind of
fine-tune and optimize things from there
okay okay now I want to talk about
anti-nutrients that's a big one too now
I love the you know you shouldn't be
eating the foods with anti-nutrients
where is that claim coming from and what
are your thoughts on it
so we might we probably have to like
step through two or three of these okay
lectins come out phytates come up and
oxalates okay they're probably the big
three there's also tannins and saponins
and
um you know goitrogens right you could
spend all day discussing yeah yeah but
those three the big three so lectins uh
you know what are like I I think firstly
back to what I said earlier about people
having very strong opinions about
lectins
I think a lot of people say that and
they're not even fully familiar with
what electing is yeah totally so electin
is a protein there's over 500 different
types of lectins found in plant Foods
and the claim is that lectins negatively
affect the gut lining
that leads to separation of What's
called the tight junctions and it
creates these gaps that allows compounds
to flow from the intestine into the
bloodstream that ordinarily wouldn't and
they provoke an inflammatory response
that separation of the tight junctions
in Sciences called increased intestinal
permeability in Lay sort of language is
called leaky gut right so lectins leaky
gut inflammation that's the narrative
that's out there right so therefore we
should be very scared of
the most lectin-containing foods which
is legumes and whole grains
so we kind of need to step through this
let's start with let's start zooming in
on the claims and the evidence that they
someone might put forward that is in
support of this and this came mostly
from Stephen gundry who wrote plant
paradox
a few years back he sort of put this on
the map and then people have run with it
and he conveniently he sells a
supplement called lectin Shield so he
created the problem and he sells you the
solution but I was incredibly interested
to I read his book and I wanted to know
what is the evidence that he's putting
forward here
um
and so firstly
he cites studies looking at animal
studies where they take isolated lectins
so this isn't people not people or
animals being fed of Whole Food
literally extract the lectin out give a
very high dose to an animal and see what
happens see if you can increase
inflammation and there are some studies
that show that but we have to understand
that one compound from the food that we
isolate out
in an animal study I mean how how can we
generalize that to a human that would
never happen in real life that isolated
compound could behave and and very
likely does very differently when it's
in Whole Food form Matrix and when it's
being consumed by humans in a dose that
they would be exposed to in their diet
ordinarily so that's that's the first
thing that the predominantly what he's
doing is citing animal studies
secondly he does cite some human studies
and so there are studies showing people
that consumed legumes There Was You Know
varying degrees of of toxicity
all of these studies and it's very clear
in them they're case studies were when
humans were consuming improperly
prepared legumes what does that mean so
that's not soaking and boiling
which you would do if you were buying
sort of dried beans yeah when you're
buying canned beans that's already done
for you okay and so how are you eating
legumes if you're not boiling it well
hey you can you can boil it and not boil
it for long enough and so the way to the
way to know this is if you bite into a
legume and I don't recommend eating them
if they're like this because if they're
still a little bit hard and crunchy yeah
they should be very soft you should put
it between your molars and they just
squish down like the enchiladas we had
last year yeah they were very good so
and the reason for that is that when you
soak and cook these Foods properly 93 to
96 of the lectins are destroyed oh my
gosh and there is study after study
showing that so the one the human
studies like they just
properly they just didn't cook them
properly and it's actually noted in the
studies like these were people who had
toxicity so and then the other thing
that gundry cites and he makes a big
deal of it he says that there is
peer-reviewed evidence that lectins are
inflammatory damaging to human health
and if you actually look up that
citation
it's an abstract that he wrote
in a journal sure but it's just an
abstract summarizing a poster that he
had at a conference
which is just explaining anecdotal case
studies that he saw as a doctor that's
not a clinical trial that's not people
who are randomized to a diet that was
low lectin and a high lectin diet and
looked at outcomes
right there there could be many reasons
why his results were what they were
they're going to be affected by all
sorts of biases terribly weak data and
then you know so we could almost just
stop there but let's just zoom out and
think about this a little bit more let's
look at
people the people that are eating the
most legumes
what's a health like long term and we
actually see a dose dependent response
again here we see that as people
increase their legume consumption up to
about 400 grams a week and then it
plateaus up to 400 grams a week they're
reducing their risk of all sorts of
chronic diseases cancer cardiovascular
disease events and mortality
and that's I guess two or three cups you
know every every sort of piece of
information that we have about the
lectin story suggests that it's not
something to fear if you're properly
preparing your foods I don't recommend
slow cooking legumes slow cooking
legumes is usually done at a lower
temperature okay and when you slow cook
legumes and it's below 100 degrees you
actually can get an increase in lectins
so that's something for people to be
mindful of and just being mindful of
when you're when you're eating whole
grains and you're eating lectins are
they cooked are they do they taste
cooked or do they taste crunchy and hard
yeah if they taste crunchy and hard then
you know you probably want to take them
back to the pot and cook them properly I
can't believe that about the study that
they just were just
in a way that you people don't eat you
don't really want to eat legumes like
that yeah and there's a I put this on my
phone but there's a paper that I'll give
you that people can read it's called is
there such a thing as anti-nutrients a
narrative review of perceived
problematic plant compounds by Petrosky
okay and so there's there's kind of like
a really nice summary of of some of
those things that I just discussed and
does that include like all the different
anti-nutrients yeah so phytates and
oxalates and oxalates is super
interesting okay let's get into that one
uh that's one that Paul saladino talks
about I think he talks about phytates
too so I mean oxalates the main claim is
that oxalates bind calcium and they
increase risk of calcium oxalate kidney
stones
first thing for people to understand
here is that more than 50 percent of
oxalates that are in your circulation
and not from your diet
your body makes them
okay so that's a really important point
because often people are sort of
suggesting that any food that contains
oxalates or should steer clear of but
they're completely unaware of the
physiology that our body actually makes
oxalates and we have a system in place
to get rid of them they get filtered out
by the kidney in excreted through the
urine
um so that's the first thing to realize
the second thing is there are studies
looking at
different dietary patterns and people
with calcium oxalate kidney stones what
are the best dietary patterns for these
people yeah and it's quite clear and
there's no studies looking at a plant's
exclusive vegan diet but there is
studies looking at a vegetarian diet and
the vegetarian diet is associated with
the lowest risk of these calcium oxalate
is that possible even though it's high
in oxalates here's here's what it comes
down to
High oxalates is only High dietary
oxalates it's only going to be a problem
for someone who's consuming insufficient
amounts of calcium and this is why
anyone who if someone's listening who
had has a history of calcium oxalate
kidney stones they one of the first
things they'll be told by their
physician is make sure you're getting
enough calcium in your diet because when
you're consuming a diet that's high in
oxalates but has low calcium much more
of that oxalate will be absorbed but
when your consuming diet that's rich in
calcium and has high oxalates the
calcium is binding to the oxalates and
they get excreted through the body
they're not even absorbed into
circulation
so
if someone's eating a plant-based diet
and they're getting enough calcium
there's no issue here the only time
someone would really ever run into a
problem with oxalates in a plant-based
diet is if for some reason they had no
diversity and they chose to get all of
their calcium from really high oxalate
foods like spinach and rhubarb greens
okay but if you're eating with diversity
and you've got these low oxalate greens
like kale and Rocket or arugula or
whatever you call it in your diet then
you have you know nothing to worry about
there
the the other interesting thing here is
that the endogenous production of
oxalates is really interesting because
when you consume more animal protein
and it's it's not fully understood how
this occurs but it's thought to be the
type of amino acids particularly amino
acids like hydroxyproline it actually
increase the amount of oxalates your
body produces High animal protein diets
are very strongly associated with
calcium oxalate kidney stones as is high
sodium
so generally the recommendations for
someone if they want to avoid a calcium
oxide kidney stone or they have them and
they don't want to get another one
or exacerbate it is to make sure you
have enough calcium in your diet
to make sure you have enough potassium
which is fruits and vegetables and we
know very clearly people who consume
more fruits and vegetables have less
kidney stones and what's the calcium
recommendations you have you want to get
at least north of seven 800 milligrams a
day from what sources so you can go dark
leafy greens cruciferous vegetables
you've got your white beans have calcium
in them a lot of the kind of soy milk or
plant-based milks now will have them you
can get some tofu calcium set tofu
sesame seeds you know all of those sorts
of things yeah are going to be where you
get it from and you want to try and
Target seven to eight hundred milligrams
or north of that per day and if someone
wanted to track that they can use an app
like chronometer and just put a day of
eating in and kind of see where they
land but enough calcium enough potassium
de-emphasizing animal protein and
de-emphasizing sodium sodium is another
one that really drives up the risk of
these kidney stones
um these are these are more things for
people to focus on if they have a family
history of a calcium oxalate kidney
stone or if they've had one themselves
so I want to talk about Paul saladino we
talked about hit the oxalate and I want
to get into the phytate too but you
worked out with him recently how how did
that go it was fun like he he's a you
know uh a nice charismatic dude and you
know we had a good chat and
um we disagree on a lot of things but we
also agree on quite a number of things
so uh yeah I had a good time and
hopefully
in the future at some point we can kind
of sit down and flesh things out but we
worked out for two or three hours we we
literally trained everything that we
could everybody apart
and just chatted about science and our
different views and yeah it was it was a
it was a very interesting but it was
like a friendly conversation yeah yeah
yeah I disagree a lot with Paul but
I also appreciate that he's changed his
views a few times on on certain things
yeah it seems open to that as have I
I've changed my view on certain things
over the years so I think if I was going
to have a discussion with someone that
Hazard comes to this from a different
angle then he would be a good person to
to do that with yes I would love I would
love to do that conversation just maybe
one day we'll put it out there with Paul
sardino and you guys would make an
amazing match
um so something else he talks about a
lot is Phi Tates and what do you think
he says phytates will rob you of
minerals yeah that's the main thing
where is he in that claim so there is
some truth that phytates can bind
minerals particularly iron and zinc
uh again phytates are largely destroyed
when you cook soak Foods so phytates are
a kind of you know found mostly in whole
grains in Salmon legumes and nuts and
seeds
um
and Paul will point to a single study
where there was a single meal right
looking at you know a high phytate kind
of meal and what happened to the
absorption of certain minerals yeah and
that's interesting
but we have more evidence showing that
the body is very adaptive so as you
habitually consume a high phytate diet
the body responds so in that single meal
you might see reduced mineral absorption
but there's it's a great study looking
at post-menopausal women and iron
absorption with high phytate diets and
when you get them consuming it
habitually for weeks what happens the
body ramps up iron absorption it adjusts
so this is another example of just like
looking at the study in context
understanding what other evidence is out
there and then and why am I doing that
maybe the person's not used to eating
those Foods so when you just start on
that it's going to have a different kind
of response when you don't normally eat
that food
yeah and and so they're you know it's
certainly I think again properly
preparing your Foods is important it
will increase the mineral availability
in your food particularly iron and zinc
and if someone has low iron then they
might want to think about this even more
so what are some of the things that you
can do if you're consuming plant foods
that contain phytates other than just
preparing them properly to increase iron
absorption and zinc absorption
there's a few different things one is
increase the sources of vitamin C in
your diet so squeezing lime or lemon
juice on a salad or eating bell peppers
um or capsicum we call them in Australia
with food they're really rich in in
vitamin C things of of that nature will
increase absorption of iron cooking with
garlic and onion
um both of these alliums increase iron
absorption so if you're whatever kind of
stir fry or whatever dinner you're
preparing if you can work garlic and
onion in they will significantly
increase the absorption of iron and zinc
and then the other one is fermented
foods so fermented foods also will
increase the bioavailability of iron and
zinc and other minerals that are that
are in your food so if you know that's
probably too much for someone to focus
on if their iron levels are fine yeah
but if you're noticing that your iron
levels are low then you might want to
kind of look into that yeah I think all
this stuff is super interesting about
the phytates and the oxalates and then
even as far as like the saturated fat
and unsaturated fat I feel like
sometimes it feels like it's missing the
component of just a holistic perspective
like I'm actually even surprised that
Paul would be look at looking at it in
that way like one specific mechanism in
a food I know that's like science but I
like I I feel like if you just take a
step back it just reminds me of the um
the book whole we're thinking the
science of nutrition by T Colin Campbell
the nutritional biochemist I love that
book that was one of my favorite
nutrition books what do you think about
that about his complaint about looking
at science in the wrong way like
focusing on one specific nutrient in a
food or something a component of a I
think that the scientists and
researchers are aware of that right so
like for example in this case yeah you
have the single meal study where they
look at one food that's high in phytate
and look at Mineral absorption yeah
there are studies looking at at mixed
meals and the raising mixed meals is
important is that you know you have
things like vitamin C and and garlic and
onion in a mixed Meal which is more
representative of how someone would eat
in real life yeah right so it's not that
that the researchers are unaware of this
the problem is when you're trying to
build a case on social media and you
just go and select one piece of that
evidence yeah absolutely um I think in
this case when you look at the overall
evidence it's quite clear that
you know phytates aren't something that
people need to be scared of if if
anything and this is an emerging area of
science phytes have anti-cancer
properties so they're being looked at
very heavily for treatment during cancer
wow and they seem to you know there's a
few different mechanisms but they seem
to reduce free radicals and oxidative
stress damage to cells so
um I think that's worth noting as well
as you know these are often painted as
harmful bad compounds but they they
might also be beneficial at a certain
doses a certain type of thing that's
interesting uh for people listening
Simon and I have been going back and
forth about saturated fat and coconut
because I tend to just naturally feel
like coconut is obviously a health food
just like living in Hawaii it just feels
it makes sense to me but you have a
problem with looking at food in that way
into looking at it with the scientific
perspective but I'm curious maybe you
can we can get into it just a tiny bit
about is it possible that the studies
unsaturated fat
or just in general anything poofa is all
of it are missing that maybe it's not
just the saturated fat or just the
polyunsaturated fat that's affecting the
health outcome it's the holistic part of
the food so is it possible that the
saturated fat in coconut is going to
respond differently in our bodies than
the saturated fat and red meat
it's not just possible we know that so
it's not as though these studies haven't
sort of separated out different foods
and different types of saturated fat and
looked at their unique effects on lipids
that has been done and there are some
subtle differences though when it comes
to Coconut but when you look at say the
effect of saturated fats found typically
in a food like red meat or butter and
you compare those to the saturated fats
in coconut oil now they both raise LDL
cholesterol but the butter the saturated
fats in butter and in red meat on a gram
per gram basis increase LDL cholesterol
more than coconut oil in that case right
where the data is a little bit limited
on coconut is a couple of places
one is that
unlike the saturated fats that are in
red meat where we have heart health
outcome data we know that they actually
increase events remember I spoke about
those trials
with coconut oil all we have is this
data that shows that coconut oil raises
LDL cholesterol and as we went over
before we have reason to believe
strongly that that means they're going
to have an increased risk of
cardiovascular disease but we don't have
the longer term trials with coconut
products showing actual increases in
events right so we're kind of we are
speculating a little bit more on coconut
than we would say on a food like butter
or red meat which we know much more
about
the other layer here is
how important is the food Matrix so I'm
hoping that the listener is one thing
that they take home is that the food
Matrix is really important and it
affects how saturated fats affect your
physiology the example I gave before was
that yogurt and cheese has a different
effect on your blood lipids than butter
because the more refined it became it
affected the way that those saturated
fats were absorbed and ultimately how
that affect blood lipids now it may well
be a very similar thing with coconut
coconut oil may have a a different or
significantly different effect on blood
lipids than eating coconut flesh so
I'm sounding like a broken record here
but what I would say is if you're
including coconut products in your diet
it's the same rule as before you can't
meaningfully change something or
understand your risk if you're not
measuring so go and measure APO b or
non-hdl whatever is available to you
where can you go measure that you just
see your physician and ask for a blood
test and say to them is does this test
include non-hdl which most tests
routinely should and you can go the
extra step and say hey I'd like to order
a per B now they may have a small charge
for that you can work out whether you're
prepared to pay that or not or you can
just use the non-hdl which is you know
correlates pretty well with apob in most
circumstances
um so I'm just being picky when I'm
saying get a per B non-hgl is pretty
damn good predictor of cardiovascular
disease okay so moral of the story is to
test your levels know where you're at
and then you can tweak and titrate
saturated fat in your diet you know we
spoke about some of the food swaps that
someone might look at before
to get to an optimal apob level such
that when you're walking around in your
day-to-day and you're going to bed at
night you're not laying down this fatty
Pike in your arteries that's that's what
we're that's what we're trying to get to
the principle of science is that context
matters right so I don't see that in
fear and say science hasn't worked it
out it's all over the place yeah I say
hey how can we explain this and when
it's it is fully explainable it's just
it's not something that you can deliver
in one sentence yeah so it requires a
bit more of an in-depth discussion now
that is different arguably though to
what you would say to someone when
you're just you know if I was sitting
down with someone just trying to tell
them how to eat I'm not going into all
of those details necessarily I would
explain high level what are the
characteristics of a healthy dietary
pattern which we did I'd give them
choice they could choose the one that
they the the variant that they thought
they could adhere to best and then I'd
say okay what what you're going to do is
you're going to adopt that diet and then
we're going to measure some things over
time let's make sure that that diet is
working for you we know what biomarkers
predict disease so we start you off with
a healthy dietary pattern then let's
measure some things let's look at apob
let's look at fasting glucose HBA 1C
triglycerides your blood pressure let's
use those lab tests in addition to using
functional tests like let's look at your
cardio respiratory Fitness your your
strength these types of things that we
know all to all together they they come
together coalesce to predict your
longevity how well you're going to live
so that that's kind of you know my
overall approach but I I I don't think
this is a case of science hasn't worked
it out I think that it's just science
showing us that context really matters
yeah but can it be work can it work
really well cohesively with things like
our biology so do you ever use the
argument of how the length of our
intestines compared to the length of a
length of a lion's intestines or is that
not is that like a moot point for you
it's not a moot point I think it's I
think that stuff is interesting
um but I I certainly don't think it's
anywhere near as compelling as looking
at heart health outcomes when someone
does something what is their risk of
having an event because that's what we
care about no that makes are we going to
so I think that there's a whole lot more
speculation and extrapolation required
to go from anthropology to saying okay
based on anthropology we should eat this
way I think you have to you have to make
a ton of assumptions whereas I think
that some of the more refined approaches
of science that are looking and trying
to control for variables and looking at
specific exposures and looking at heart
health outcomes yeah and some of the
biomarkers that are established as good
predictors of disease I think that's a
much more meaningful
way to determine what food choices are
going to improve our health span yeah I
think the concern that people often have
is that we might be going in the wrong
direction in places like take presents
plant milk so a lot of people have this
concern of skepticism about plant milk
now it's trendy to think that you know
you're naturally now should be getting
milk from a your backyard cow get a cow
and have your own backyard raw milk and
that bottled plant milk is not good for
you doesn't enhance your health whereas
maybe someone in your realm might be
thinking well the science shows that
when you add supplemental vitamin D to
this uh you know
for this processed food because we
wouldn't plant milk be considered a
processed food it would be but I
wouldn't say that a processed food
inherently is harmful yeah yeah not
totally this is not like Ultra processed
foods but we have to essentially almost
I hate using this word but biohack yeah
to to get get our physiology or help our
physiology stay healthy for for longer
um but to to the point about like plant
milks you know I would agree with some
of the skepticism there are things that
I would look out for like if you were if
you were buying plant milks again we
have to consider okay so what is someone
taking out of their diet so if they're
taking out Dairy which I said earlier
can feature within a healthy dietary
pattern if someone's taking it out
usually that's maybe they're lactose
intolerant or for planetary health or
Animal Welfare reasons if they're
removing those foods from their diet
then we want to make sure that their
getting adequate amount of calcium
protein vitamin D Etc and also at the
same time you know ideally they're not
swapping for a plant milk that is super
loaded with refined sugars so I think
you can make sensible swaps and then you
can make swaps that really don't make
sense from a nutrition point of view and
reading the label is you know an
important starting point there yeah so
let's move on to the next one beef liver
what do you think about the hype that
beef liver is very good for you and it's
a superfood if if I was eating an only
meat diet then I probably would eat
organs okay right because they do
contain certain nutrients that you
wouldn't get otherwise or you it would
be very hard to get yeah
um
so in that context
sure but I would also be really aware
that if you eat too much you run the
risk of vitamin A toxicity some of these
are very heavily concentrated and more
is not always better vitamin A toxicity
excess vitamin A has been linked with
various forms of cancer excess iron some
of these organs are very rich in iron we
know that that can cause oxidative
stresses linked with type 2 diabetes and
cardiovascular disease
so in that particular context where
someone doesn't have fruits and
vegetables and is missing out on a bunch
of these nutrients you could create an
argument for it but if you're eating an
otherwise healthy diet with lots of
fruits and vegetables you don't need
augments and this whole idea of vitamin
A toxicity is the amount that you'd have
to eat to reach that point a lot of of
organ meats or is it very highly
concentrated it wouldn't actually be
that much the exact number of grams I'd
have to kind of look up it's not
something that I'm looking at every day
but yeah uh yeah you could you could
easily reach that amount in a week like
exceed the up yeah and so why does the
these other cams going back to someone
like Paul saladino is he looking at the
evidence differently than you or what
does he think about the evidence
comparison well I think he just falls
into the naturalistic fallacy and and is
convincing himself that whatever our
ancestors ate is best from a longevity
point of view which I've kind of
explained I would strongly do disagree
with yeah
um so he he does that and then he kind
of tries to find Cherry picks evidence
to
um argue against you know some of these
positions that we've gone through like
cherry pick a phytate study looking at a
single feeding thing or a cherry pick a
lectin study looking at feeding isolated
lectins to mice but not looking at the
actual bigger picture where you're
looking at people eating lots of lecting
containing foods having Better Health
outcomes
um so largely we have a different view
of the evidence hierarchy so he's mutt
seems to be much more focused in sort of
short-term anecdote and ancestral sort
of
um line of thinking I'm more interested
in
looking at a human exposure both through
observational studies and in clinical
trials and meta-analyzes of of clinical
trials I think that's a much more robust
valid reliable way of determining what's
healthy in the long term right but
something he's done is criticize
something like epidemiological studies
but then use an epidemiological study to
promote something that he just really
want wants yeah that's good he does that
a lot he cited he actually cited that
Chen paper that I mentioned before that
looks at Dairy fats okay and that's the
one where you can show that Dairy was
reducing cardiovascular disease risk
relative to the types of saturated fat
found in red meat but in the same
analysis they looked at Dairy compared
to polyunsaturated fats and that bit was
conveniently left out left out
um that you know people that were eating
more polyunsaturated fats had even lower
risk of cardiovascular disease
um so there's that's an example of a
logical kind of inconsistency one is not
representing that paper completely
um sort of transparently yeah to the
people that he's communicating with and
then secondly that study is an
epidemiological observational study so
you can't take the position elsewhere
that epidemiology is terrible food
frequency questionnaires are terrible
yet then find an epidemiology study that
you like because it's a food that you
like to consume and cite it you know
that's that's double standards that's
being inconsistent that's really helpful
for people to see when they're deciding
where to take who to take information
from because you know most of the people
listening like myself we don't know how
to read research so we have to trust the
source that we're listening to so you
want to find somebody that's being
logically consistent across the board
that's something you're doing very
differently than even a lot of the
plant-based doctors willing to admit
that you know fatty fish could be a
potentially better swap than than other
things and also like you said certain
types of data like fermented dairy
that's not something you're not really
that you're hearing from other
plant-based doctors and it's possible
that our the biases are coming into play
just like we're accusing this other diet
realm of doing so we picked on
um ancestral diets a lot
but there's actually like a lot that you
do agree with like you said and you know
what I I really commend anyone that has
like just taken the initiative
and has the willpower to change their
diet and move away from the status quo
of a standard diet that's not serving
them um I just want people to understand
that there are other options and there
are tweaks and things that they can do
to go to the next level and feel
healthier for for longer so I don't want
it to to seem like I'm picking on that
the individual I understand why people
adopt these diets and I understand that
people in the short term feel better and
I think that's amazing I just want
people to be aware of some of these
other factors maybe that aren't being
communicated by the people that they're
listening to so that in 30 years time
they they don't have any regrets there
yeah that's amazing so what is something
specific within the vegan
cancel from both sides oh where do we
start
uh
you know I think one of the the more
problematic
um and you kind of alluded actually to
one thing within the vegan Community
it's just this this kind of General
notion that a plant exclusive vegan diet
is the healthiest diet you can't make
that you cannot make that argument
scientifically it's extremely difficult
to do that yeah you would have to be
very inconsistent in the way that you're
looking at evidence
um so I think for up front first and
foremost is that animal foods can
feature in a healthy diet and if they're
in there like you said it probably is
leaning more towards fatty fish and kind
of fermented types of yogurt and cheese
and smaller amounts yeah and smaller
amounts it's a plant-rich diet those are
not necessarily the hero of the plate
they're more of a kind of side dish and
that diet has been described all the way
back you know since the early research
looking at heart disease that came out
of
um Henry Blackburn and Ansel Keys work
so I think that's the first thing is
that really the strongest argument to
adopt a vegan diet is based on planetary
health or Animal Welfare particularly
Animal Welfare
um and and I think what people
thought the Trap they fall into is
because they're so passionate about
Animal Welfare or planetary Health that
now let's just go find evidence that's
going to create this argument that the
vegan diet's the best diet I don't think
you need to do that I think all you need
to to be able to explain is that if you
adopt a thoughtfully constructed plants
exclusive diet you can be really healthy
there are some things you need to think
about there are some nutrients of focus
every single diet has limitations let's
air them let's be aware of the
limitations let's adopt it in a way
where it's optimized and then it's in
line with the values that you have
so that's the first thing the second is
I'd say like when you sort of drill down
a bit more specifically into the the
construction of a plant-based diet
there and this is kind of fading but
there has been a message for low-fat
vegan diets
I've never really been a big fan of that
and there's a few reasons one I think
that it often leads to people consuming
insufficient calories and and you know
I've worked with enough women to to see
that on on such diets where they're
super low in fat particularly if they're
an active person then and then they're
consuming insufficient calories you know
it can really mess with their hormones
they can lose their period yeah all
sorts of your fertility right so all
sorts of cascade of things can occur if
you're adopting a diet that's not
nourishing you and providing you with
enough energy yeah that can happen when
you go super low fat it's very low
calorie density it's high volume food
and if you're not a big eater yeah you
can fall into that also because it's
just not as delicious like when you're
not eating food that's as delicious it's
hard to eat enough calories now the flip
side of that is and where these diets
where we've kind of made an error is
that there are studies showing that
those diets can be really good for
someone with really poor metabolic
Health who needs to lose a lot of weight
that's a different content next to a
woman in her 30s right yeah who's at a
completely different life stage she's
metabolically healthy she's active maybe
she wants to have kids all that sort of
stuff
so I don't like low fat because from the
perspective for certain people it can
lead to energy restriction
it can affect your absorption of fat
soluble vitamins so a d e and K which
can be problematic
and
perhaps most importantly it's limiting
polyunsaturated and monounsaturated fats
which I think the evidence clearly shows
are inherently beneficial these are not
these are not compounds that we want to
avoid we actually want them to be in our
diet because they keep us insulin
sensitive they drive down APO B which
means we're getting less of that fatty
pipe building up in the arteries so
they're probably like the the the the
big ticket items where I would disagree
yeah with people in the vegan Community
I'm sure there's more but those are the
big ones do you know where they got this
uh Concepts that we should be eating
lower fat well it's from the doctors
it's from studies like Dean ornish's
lifestyle heart study which was looking
at people with you know it's a secondary
prevention study so they have these
These are sick people that have heart
disease they're overweight like
you know in that circumstance you kind
of need to throw everything at it yeah
and and it's a very different context to
this the average person who's thinking
about adopting a plant-based diet yeah
so I think what's happened is those
studies came out mainly The Dana orange
one also esselstyn study which we could
talk about that for a long time but
that's not actually a controlled trial
it's more of a case study it's very hard
to to deduce any solid findings from
that but Dean ornish's
his clinical trial which again it's not
just diet they also stop smoking they
started exercising they did stress
reduction so a little bit hard to say
it's just the diet
but the dietary intervention nonetheless
was low fat and so what happened off the
back of that was
you know a lot of uh books and a lot of
Articles and a lot of conferences people
talking about low-fat being the best for
heart disease and you know somehow
that's been generalized just to everyone
doing that but the issue with that is
firstly the type of people that they
were studying were quite sick but
secondly we have other evidence clinical
trials that have looked at low-fat diets
versus
higher fat diets but with a bias for
unsaturated fats and there's a recent
one called the cordioprev this is a
seven year randomized control trial and
this trial unlike the dean ornish one
the only thing they changed was diet so
you get a much better look at the actual
inherent benefits of diet
now some people might argue that the low
fat version wasn't low enough but still
it was much lower than the group who
were having higher fat but from olive
oil and unsaturated fat sources
over seven years what happened who did
better the low-fat diet and these were
both healthy whole food diets who does
better low-fat or the high fat with the
unsaturated fat bias
the latter the high fat unsaturated fat
buyers had significantly less
cardiovascular disease they had better
flu mediation
mediated dilation which means their
arteries were actually operating better
and they had less
plaque built up in their carotid artery
so they had regression of any plaque
that was in there so
I think that you know we can't ignore
evidence like that there's there's and
that's not the only bit of evidence
there's other clinical trials that show
that speak to these unsaturated fats
being inherently beneficial so you know
I like to communicate that so that
people don't see fat as like it's we
don't have to demonize Fat we need to
understand that fat is an umbrella term
and even how I explained before
saturated fats and umbrella term but if
we just simplify and we say Fat's an
umbrella term underneath it you have
saturated fats monounsaturated fats and
your polyunsaturated fats rather than
thinking about like restricting total
fat think about the quality of the fats
you're eating what foods are providing
the fats yeah and if those Foods tend to
be fatty fish if you eat seafood or nuts
seeds tofu and avocado and olive oil or
avocado oil things of that nature then
those fats are completely healthy for
you and you shouldn't fear them yes I
love that I love my avocado I eat so
much avocado on my diet and it makes me
feel so good and I think that it is
definitely a part of a healthy diet
specifically for women like you said
women in their fertility age is it's so
important and healthful to eat healthy
amounts of fats and I think really
considering about how one of the main
reasons why so many people or why people
often stop eating plant-bases often
they're not eating enough calories and
it's a lot harder to get enough calories
when you're not eating healthy fat
sources so that's a really important to
talk about I'm glad you brought that up
so just kind of round it out
what is the point of all this is it
longevity is it feeling your best in the
current moment and I think that could be
just be like an individual answer for
people but is it when you're looking at
science is it anything other than just
longevity is it also feeling good right
now or is it is the science show that
the that longevity and feeling good
right now are cohesive they're cohesive
but I also think this probably requires
like a bit of a deeper
philosophical contamination so today's
question right so like why do we want to
live longer and I read a study recently
and it was looking at people before they
were dying and what their biggest
regrets were
the biggest regret was that they didn't
live the life that they wanted to live
they lived a life that others wanted
them to live oh wow so I think if if
we're going to have this conversation
about longevity first and foremost it's
examining you know why do we love life
are we living the life that we want to
to live and when we are and you feel
that of course you want to live for as
long as possible yes so we kind of I
think we reframe that rather than just
this scientific pursuit of just living
long yeah we really want to live better
and not just physically but emotionally
and so getting clear on like why do we
want to do that it's going to be a
little bit different for each person I
think that's kind of the starting point
and then that can kind of hold people to
some of these things that we've been
discussing and behavior change and
building it into to becoming a lifestyle
with a bit more meaning yes totally and
it helps look at it at a holistic
perspective to that it's not just about
food feeling good longevity it's so
clearly not just about food right I've
got these Retreats at the end of this
year and the whole focus is on
it's on it's on like longevity
optimization right and going into it I
was thinking like what can I impart on
the people that are coming like how can
I be most effective here and to your
point that it's not just nutrition like
nutrition is just a tiny not a tiny but
it's it's a it's a chunk of what we're
going to be exploring but we're really
going to teach people about all of the
different biomarkers and predictors of
longevity and then how to intervene on
that through nutrition through exercise
and movement which we haven't spoken
about but that's you know a huge part
here through stress reduction and
practices to improve your emotional
health and happiness now all of this
really matters at the end of the day
yeah I love it thank you so much for
being here I think this is a great way
to end this conversation we touched on
so much a lot of your conversations on
your podcast can get quite long too
right because there's honing on like a
specific you could do a whole episode
is the longest four hours that's super
that was a debate that was actually a
debate on seed oils oh I watched that
one seed oils versus saturated fat yeah
you moderated it I moderated I watched
that one definitely some of it went over
my head but it was very interesting yeah
I love debates I think debates are the
best
um but thank you so much for being here
we've had such a great time with you so
far we have a few more days till you
leave and looking forward to getting a
surf in yes yes but it's a yeah it's a
it's a pleasure of Lofton Thanks for
opening up your house of course hanging
out love your kids beautiful oh thank
you Andrew so yeah yeah it's been
amazing and I just feel grateful yeah in
part of me so awesome thanks for being
here we're gonna end it right now
foreign
[Music]